responsabilité du gouvernement
conformément au disposition de l'article
49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution le texte
sur lequel la première ministre engage
la responsabilité du gouvernement sera
insérée en annexe au compte-rendu de la
présence
en application de l'article 155 à Linéa
premier de notre règlement le débat sur
ce texte est immédiatement suspendu ce
texte sera considéré comme adopté sauf
si une motion de censure est déposée
avant demain 15h20 et voter dans les
conditions prévues à l'article 49 de la
Constitution dans l'hypothèse une motion
de censure serait déposée la Conférence
des Présidents fixera la date et les
modalités de sa discussion la séance est
levée
position pour faire face pour redonner
la main à la population pour qu'elle
puisse exprimer son opposition qui est
massive dans le pays à ce projet de
casse de notre droit à la retraite nous
n'acceptons pas ce qui vient de se
passer nous disons au gouvernement qu'il
n'est pas légitime à exercer un pouvoir
limite dans ce pays l'opposition elle
est massive elle s'est exprimée dans la
rue dans les entreprises dans les grèves
elle a continué de s'exprimer ce dernier
jour notre pays ne l'accepte pas le
gouvernement n'est pas à la hauteur de
sa responsabilité en procédant de la
sorte il se rend lui-même illégitime
pour la suite des événements il est pas
à la hauteur des crises que nous
traversons de la crise sociale de la
crise économique de la crise
démocratique de la crise écologique de
la crise de la paix dans le monde c'est
de tout cela dont il faut s'occuper pas
de casser le droit à la retraite dans
notre pays
c'est plus qu'un déni démocratie la
première ministre en annonçant le 49.3
vient de finir du millier de bafouer le
Parlement une bonne fois pour toute ce
gouvernement cette première ministre
n'est pas digne de notre démocratie
n'est pas digne de la République cette
réforme est complètement illégitime
aujourd'hui la mobilisation doit se
poursuivre nous la poursuivrons et
aujourd'hui la suite c'est le rip le
réfrigérateur que nous allons déposer
défendre et pendant les 9 mois qui vont
suivre pour obtenir ces 4 millions de
signatures cette réforme devra être
suspendue et donc nous avons encore
l'espoir de
faire respecter le monde du travail et
de créer les conditions que cette
réforme ne soit jamais mise en
application en rendant le pouvoir au
peuple
mais la motion de censure la motion de
censure est prête nous créerons toutes
les conditions pour qu'elles reçoivent
le plus de soutien possible nous
souhaitons qu'elle puisse être défendue
par le groupe l'iode afin qu'elle
reçoive le plus de soutien pour notre
part nous la soutiendrons merci à vous
merci
non non non non
on vient de voir les députés communistes
qui arrivaient là ce sont ceux il me
semble monsieur Guedj qui vient
d'arriver du Parti socialiste
évidemment grosse colère alors est-ce
qu'il y a une mise en scène ou pas mais
on sent complètement une mise en scène
évidemment
regardez il se précipite ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure s'ils vont salle des
quatre colonnes vous avez vu le nombre
de caméras de journalistes de
photographe tout ça est mis en scène je
rappelle que sous
Michel Rocard le 49-3 a été déposé à 28
reprises donc voilà ils font semblant
enfin semblant ils poussent des des
Grands Prix d'orfray c'est dans la
logique de leur stratégie ce qui va être
plus intéressant au-delà de ce qu'il
faut qu'on écoute Boris vallon on est en
train de le voir à l'image et puis on
revient de l'autre côté alors peut-être
qu'on peut essayer de se tourner vers
Marine Le Pen en effet je vais essayer
de voir avec avec Julien Leclerc si
il peut se retourner parce que c'est
vrai que c'est un peu la confusion ici
alors à la salle des quatre colonnes
avec donc Marine Le Pen qui
parlait au journaliste on va essayer de
la retrouver de tant le micro avec
toutes ces personnalités donc à une Pen
elle aussi qui était contre cette
réforme des retraites
opposés à cette réforme de retraite
comme il y a une majorité de Français
opposés à cette réforme de retraite donc
c'est vrai qu'on peut se poser
véritablement des questions sur le
fonctionnement de notre démocratie dans
une circonstance telle que celle-là
c'est quand le texte ne peut pas réunir
une majorité parce que il est rejeté par
une majorité de Français il ne devrait
jamais voir le jour alors nous allons
évidemment déposer une motion de censure
il faut censurer ce gouvernement
et nous espérons que ceux qui
s'apprêtaient à voter contre cette
réforme de retraite votre nom cette
notion de censure en ce qui nous
concerne nous déposerons une notion et
nous voterons comme je l'ai annoncé il y
a des mois déjà
l'intégralité d'émotion de transition
parce qu'on est
le gouvernement doit tomber aujourd'hui
ça me paraît être une évidence comment
est-ce que le gouvernement peut encore
susciter la moindre confiance auprès des
Français alors que je crois qu'il a
perdu la confiance de la majorité de la
santé
rable de force
je veux pas que non plus qui est une
aversion totale des valeurs c'est un
constat d'échec total du gouvernement et
j'irai même plus loin c'est un constat
d'échec total pour Emmanuel Macron
car c'est sa réforme c'est lui qui l'a
porté c'était même la seule la seule
qu'il a défendu pendant la campagne
présidentielle donc c'est son échec
personnel mais les institutions
permettent de censurer un gouvernement
pas un président de la République donc
comme nous sommes respectueux des
institutions et bien nous ferons en
sorte de censurer le gouvernement est-ce
que vous appelez les Français
à aller tous les recours parlementaires
voilà pour la réaction de Marine Le Pen
je vais essayer de retrouver carnet au
milieu de cette mode de journaliste
grande confinement alors qu'est-ce qui
se passe d'un côté Marine Le Pen de
l'autre côté de la ce sont les députés
[Musique]
le panneau qui sont en train de
s'exprimer alors ce qu'on peut préciser
on va essayer de retendre nos micros
petit à petit Jean-Luc Mélenchon était
dans l'hémicycle sans être député alors
pas dans l'hémicy oui
réservés au public ce qui n'est pas
neutre parce que pendant toute la
discussion il n'était pas là on sait
qu'il était à l'extérieur de l'Assemblée
mais que avec ses tweets avec ses
messages il intervenait
un peu pour faire pression notamment
quand les députés communistes avaient
commencé à dire qu'il fallait se faire
retirer des amendements pour permettre
au texte d'aller plus vite et que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon avait un tweet pour
dire mais sûrement pas c'est pas la
bonne stratégie et comme par hasard à ce
moment-là les députés et les filles
avaient repris tous leurs amendements là
il était
sur le dans les balcons réservés au
public et il observait et il observait
quoi les députés et les filles qui se
sont mis debout enchanté la Marseillaise
pour empêcher la première ministre de
parler visiblement ce chant a été repris
par les autres députés PS écologiste
certains ont vu des députés LR qui se
sont
mis à chanter aussi la Marseillaise tout
ça sous l'oeil de Jean-Luc Mélenchon bon
très étonnant parce que c'est vrai
lorsqu'on se dit Mélenchon on nous le
dit souvent les observateurs Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est lui qui tire les
ficelles là il était clairement là pour
observer son œuvre d'une certaine
manière exactement là il prend un risque
c'est de effectivement d'apparaître
comme le marionnettiste d'autant plus
que si vous voyez la photo on le voit
lui du balcon et en dessous il y a les
députés et donc
vous vous mettez quelques fils et en
gros ça donne l'impression qu'il est
voilà le parrain de cette affaire le
grand marionnettiste je suis pas sûr les
députés et les fils à leur convient très
bien puisque c'est leur patron on va les
députés communistes les députés
socialistes et peut-être même les
députés écolos je suis pas sûr que ça
leur conviennent complètement bon car on
peut expliquer on est au milieu de cette
salle les quatre colonnes il y a tous
les jours de ce côté-là Marine Le Pen si
Julien Leclerc peut tourner un petit peu
la caméra pour qu'on arrive à voir la
présente du rassemblement national qui
s'exprime voilà ça c'est l'une des
oppositions à cette réforme des
retraites et puis lorsqu'on retourne de
l'autre côté et bien à la sortie de
l'hémicycle là c'est la gauche tout
entière alors je vois qu'ils sont unis
pour le coup parce qu'il y a des
sociétés
depuis le début alors ce qu'il faut dire
au téléspectateurs c'est que quand on
voit les images à la télé on a
l'impression que cette salle des quatre
colonnes est très grande la réalité que
vous êtes sur place c'est qu'elle est
pas si grande que ça et que comme vous
avez toute la presse et d'ailleurs si
votre caméra a pu filmer également des
journalistes de la presse internationale
qui sont là
et évidemment toute la presse française
et ben voilà on est un peu submergé
donc il y a aussi des photographes il y
a des journalistes de presse écrite
d'autres qui essayent de faire des
directs comme nous donc c'est pas simple
à la fois de temps de l'oreille de temps
de la caméra et essayer de capter un peu
tout ce qui se passe il y a des
manifestants en dehors qui sont devant
l'Assemblée nationale on a vu tout à
l'heure notamment Philippe Martinez qui
est venu le renverger toute l'Inter
syndicale était là on va essayer de
temps les micros au Carl vers les les
députés de la gauche qui viennent
expliquer pourquoi ils sont très en
colère on va essayer de tendre le micro
avec des images de Julien Leclerc
donc aujourd'hui nous sommes face à un
moment politique extrêmement grave
extrêmement grave parce que nous sommes
sur une trahison démocratique qui
revient dans les esprits comme la
trahison démocratique il y a eu en 2005
dans notre pays
la fusible Elisabeth borne vient
d'utiliser le centième 49.3 de
l'histoire de la 5e République
ce qui est une défaite pour ce
gouvernement avec absolument haut qu'une
légitimité pour ce texte de loi ni
légitime mettez populaire il n'y a qu'à
voir les millions de personnes qui
manifesté par vous dans le pays ni
légitime était parlementaire puisque
tout a été utilisé du 47 ans jusqu'au 44
3 jusqu'à aujourd'hui ce 49-3 qui sont
autant d'articles de la Constitution qui
permettent d'arrêter les débats et de
museler et de piétiner le Parlement et
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
jusque aux travailleurs grévistes tu
essaie d'abord à eux que je veux penser
aujourd'hui en leur disant que si nous
avons fait subir une défaite à ce
gouvernement c'est notamment grâce à la
mobilisation extraordinaire de celles
des œufs qui perdent encore des salaires
aujourd'hui et qui continueront de le
faire je l'espère parce que ce que nous
voulons dire avant
c'est que le combat est loin d'être fini
et je veux vous dire aujourd'hui que
nous sommes dans un basculement
autoritaire aujourd'hui commence le
premier du reste du quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron de la fin du
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
lui employé l'autoritarisme comme ils
sont en train de le faire pour passer en
force une réforme des retraites dont
personne ne veut et sur lequel avait de
faiblesse suprême ils sont obligés
d'utiliser le 49.3 est un signe qu'ils
enfoncent le pays de réussite et nous le
disons à toutes celles et ceux qui se
mobilisent dans le pays rien n'est fini
et à ceux qui au pouvoir aujourd'hui Sam
le chaos dans ce pays nous répondrons
évidemment par la censure
nous irons avec d'autres groupes déposés
d'émotions de censure mais nous
employons tous les moyens à notre
disposition pour continuer cette lutte
que mène des millions de gens dans le
pays et que demande je le rappelle 80%
des Français 93% des actifs et je
rappelle que dans les sondages que vous
présentez vous-même 65%
qu'ils veulent que la mobilisation se
compte même avec un passage encore
cette mobilisation ne va pas s'arrêter
là nous emploiement tous les moyens
évidemment motion de censure qui se
rattrape par tisane évidemment aussi la
saisine du Conseil constitutionnel nous
ferons avec la nuit pêche le référendum
d'initiative partagée parce que il
permet de bloquer une réforme pendant 9
mois et aussi évidemment nous
continuerons ce que nous avons fait de
manière très forte avec les caisses de
grève pour aider les travailleurs et
travailleuses qui se font fortement
réprimer comme nous l'avons été ce matin
sur des parlementaires apparemment
plus
utile de prendre des précautions et donc
avec les travailleurs
vous avez gazé et fortement poussé et
bien nous leur disons que nous allons
continuer les caisses de grève qui leur
permet de tenir cette bataille je vous
le dis aujourd'hui rien n'est fini nous
allons pouvoir faire en sorte
le gouvernement a subi une défaite
mais il suffit de continuer un peu face
à un régime extrêmement affaibli pour
pouvoir l'emporter et vous pouvez
compter sur les groupes de manifeste
pour continuer ce combat là dans la rue
qui sont
voilà Mathilde Mathilde panot Mathilde
panot qui vient de s'exprimer et qui
évidemment
mettait en œuvre toutes les armes
législatives carmélus on a bien compris
là en écoutant mathildeau qu'elle ne
comptait pas du tout s'arrêter là
Mathilde
non ce n'est qu'un début le combat
continue comme ils disent dans les
manifestations non évidemment
malgré tout c'est un échec du
gouvernement oui recours en 49 francs ça
veut dire qu'il Elisabeth borgon n'a pas
réussi à trouver une majorité ou qu'en
tout cas elle a considéré que c'était
trop fragile et donc elle s'en remet à
cet article de la Constitution qui veut
que ça soit aux oppositions de démontrer
désormais
quels sont majoritaires c'est
l'inversion de la charge de la preuve
maintenant Elisabeth borne n'a pas pu
démontrer qu'elle était majoritaire aux
oppositions de démontrer avec il va
falloir quand même justifier un projet
un peu cohérent entre toutes les
oppositions et un
à plus de 289 fois ce qui nécessiterait
ce qui est là pour le coup une alliance
entre l'opposition de gauche autour de
l'anus le RN mais également le
même peut-être il y a des indépendants
le patron de Lyon est un des premiers
intervenir qui était très très remonté
on l'a vu aussi mais on le sait on l'a
dit tout à l'heure
24 heures ça ce sera la première elle
sera votée donc demain ils ont 24 heures
pour la déposer et ensuite il faut
qu'elle soit votée dans les 48 heures
donc on sera à nouveau fixé et ensuite
elle parle du Conseil constitutionnel ça
c'est on l'évoquait hier oui c'est le
dernier obstacle du steopchase puisque
c'est vous qui avez utilisé cette image
qui est beaucoup plus parlante que mon
110 mètres qui était trop court
c'est la dernière c'est le dernier
obstacle est-ce que on sait que le
Conseil constitutionnel
il y a des doutes
la prestation qu'il
[Musique]
techniquement comme on le disait tout à
l'heure c'est compliqué que les
oppositions arrivent à être majoritaires
ça supposerait un attelage quand même
totalement incohérent entre elle ETI
rassemblement national et républicain on
sait aujourd'hui que le patron des
républicains avec ceci que le patron des
députés républicains sont hostiles au
vote d'une motion de censure en tout cas
sur ce projet là puisque eux étaient
favorables au vote et donc qui ne sont
pas du tout dans cette optique là
Marine Le Pen qui elle aussi semble
quitter Noël elle a envie de répondre à
toutes les questions Marine Le Pen
visiblement alors on a vu toutes les
oppositions la gauche la droite
la droite radicale avec Marine Le Pen on
n'a pas encore vu les députés de la
majorité ni même les membres du
gouvernement gilberté Gabriel Attali il
est passé par la salle des quatre
colonnes tout à l'heure ils ne sont pas
venus défendre l'utilisation du 49 on va
aller voir ou pas oui mais dans un
second temps là c'est le temps des
oppositions c'est normal ils sont
arrivés en premier le temps du
gouvernement arrivera après la logique
d'ailleurs voudrait que
la première ministre puisse expliquer ce
choix à la à la télévision moi je serai
pas étonné que qu'elle fasse un
vainqueur
au moins pour pour expliquer ne
serait-ce d'ailleurs parce que ces
propos ont été relativement
l'assemblée ici dans la salle des quatre
colonnes en revanche les députés de la
majorité vont venir ils vont venir
expliquer ce choix eux aussi ils sont
obligés de s'exprimer devant la presse
ne peuvent pas faire profil bas ils vont
venir c'est plus compliqué pour eux
parce que pour le coup on voit bien
qu'il y avait pas de majorité c'était
difficile même les LR vous les voyez pas
c'est difficile parce que
la fin de la journée et compliqué pour
la majorité compliqué pour les LR on
voit même pas là les LR j'allais dire
dissident en tout cas ceux qui qui
étaient prêts à voter contre vous les
voyez pas non plus avec colonnes
est-ce que Elisabeth borne désormais
étant danger est-ce que son poste est
remis en cause forcément elle avait une
mission elle n'a pas réussi à la tenir
quand on discute avec son entourage ils
disent bon il y a le 49.3 on l'a dit
tout à l'heure parce que certains mais
pas leur position mais à la fin il va y
avoir un vote de 49.3 le texte lui-même
n'est pas voté mais puisqu'il y a une
motion de censure il va y avoir un vote
pour savoir
où est la majorité
est-ce que ça suffira à la sauver c'est
pas sûr parce que évidemment sa mission
telle qu'elle a été confiée par Emmanuel
Macron c'était de trouver une majorité
il faut se replacer dans le contexte de
cet automne aujourd'hui je pense
qu'Emmanuel Macron il doit regretter
d'avoir écouté François Bayrou et
Elisabeth borne qui lui ont conseillé à
l'automne de ne pas passer par un
amendement au projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale en
disant c'est trop brusque il faut
laisser le temps de la concertation une
majorité est possible maintenant après
la concertation c'est encore plus tard
non seulement l'opposition dit que c'est
brusque c'est brutal c'est des Inde
démocratie mais en plus il n'y a aucune
majorité aujourd'hui donc le résultat
est le même peut-être même pire si
jamais
la motion de censure est votée donc
Emmanuel Macron peut considérer que les
avaient de bornes a échoué dans sa
mission oui et que
d'autant qu'on le sait c'est cette
réforme des retraites c'est finalement
le seul projet du programme qui était
vraiment très clairement identifié par
les Français c'est très réforme des
retraites du programme de l'élection
2022 et c'est manqué d'une certaine
manière alors cette réforme devrait
passer mais elle ne passe pas à quel
prix
social élevé un prix politique très
élevé la question qui Emmanuel Macron
doit se poser aujourd'hui c'est bon
qu'est-ce qui fait d'Elizabeth borne et
ce qu'elle est encore crédible à la tête
du gouvernement dans un parlement sans
majorité absolue et puis une fois que
vous avez répondu à cette question si
vous avez répondu non à cette question
c'est quelle est l'alternative oui parce
que c'est facile de dire je me sépare de
mon premier ministre mais c'est
compliqué de dire par qui je le remplace
et pourquoi faire parce que Elisabeth
borne n'a certes pas de majorité absolue
mais celui ou celle qui l'a remplacerait
n'en aurait pas plus
est-ce que certains il y avait des
luttes internes dans le gouvernement
pour aller certains poussaient pour un
vote d'autres pour le 49-3 j'imagine que
certains l'ont sur la place il y avait
pas de lutte au sens où parfois en
politique on l'entend mais on voit bien
qu'il y a des certains qui se
commençaient à se positionner c'est sûr
qu'un Gérald Darmanin peut légitimement
estimer que il a la capacité d'occuper
l'Hôtel Matignon
vous avez un Bruno Le Maire aussi qui
peut lui aussi estimer qu'il a sa place
à Matignon est-ce que Emmanuel Macron
leur fait assez confiance est-ce que ils
peuvent résoudre l'équation parce que ce
sont des anciens LR et donc une partie
du groupe LR les rejoindrait rien n'est
moins sûr aujourd'hui le groupe Air est
complètement divisé les LR sont sont
complètement déchiqués sur ce sur ce
texte et on voit mal comment les
morceaux peuvent recoller pendant qu'on
discute nous au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale Karl dans cette salle cette
fameuse salle des quatre colonnes que
nous vous décrivons depuis tout à
l'heure où les députés viennent
s'exprimer et bien il y a dehors des
manifestants et qui s'entassent devant
l'Assemblée nationale alors vous avez vu
en arrivant tout à l'heure beaucoup de
force de l'ordre autour de
l'assemblée du Palais Bourbon est-ce que
maintenant les manifestations vont
continuer peut-être encore plus avec
l'utilisation de ce 49-3 oui je pense à
certains Laurent Berger qui disait s'il
y a vote nous sommes légitimistes nous
nous inclinerons d'une certaine manière
il nous arrêterons de descendre dans la
rue mais là il n'y a pas vote et surtout
il a prévenu que l'utilisation du 49-3
lui ferait peut-être changer sa position
donc on sait que la CGT est très
remontée et très en pointe sur les sur
les manifestations et les et les
blocages si la CFDT décide de rejoindre
la CGT là on peut s'attendre
effectivement à des blocages plus
importants et ça c'est embêtant pour Le
Gardeur parce que la crise politique est
gérable la crise sociale elle peut être
compliquée parce que ça veut dire des
blocages des dépôts des raffineries qui
ne se libèrent pas peut-être à la SNCF
un conflit plus plus long on a vu
qu'elle a RATP ça se s'était plus plus
diffus mais
ça veut dire que ça jusqu'à samedi en
tout cas ça va continuer peut-être même
après bon on a vu quand même une forme
de lassitude hier dans les manifestants
moins de monde beaucoup moins de monde
dans la rue oui alors c'est ça qui est
paradoxal c'est-à-dire que entre samedi
et mardi on voit bien que le mouvement
s'essouffle dans sa mobilisation
mais que le mouvement se radicalise dans
les blocages et c'est ça qui est un peu
compliqué
on est toujours à l'intérieur de cette
salle des quatre colonnes et on essaye
de se refuler on va essayer de récupérer
les images peut-être vous avez vu les
images à l'extérieur il y a ici manuel
bonpard manuel Bompard qui est
d'une centaine de manière le dauphin de
lui on imagine qu'il transmet la parole
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon là quand elle
s'exprime ah bah totalement totalement
on a vu tout à l'heure qu'il écoutait
Mathilde panot et là il est en train de
redonner les autres éléments de langage
de la France insoumise le micro voir ce
qu'ils ont à nous dire les députés
il s'est possible ici il le souhaite
qu'il puisse être porté puisqu'ils en
avaient puisque l'hypothèse avait été
évoqué par le groupe l'iode avec
l'ensemble des groupes de la Lupette et
si des députés du
groupe ce sera émotion
de ski exprime le rejet vis-à-vis de
cette réforme des retraites à 64 ans
nous y sommes favorables Marine Le Pen a
dit qu'elle l'a votera parce que elle je
citerai pas secteur
c'était pas le meilleur de scénario cet
aprèm pour vous là
non le meilleur des scénarios c'est que
le gouvernement retire son texte de loi
il l'a pas encore fait mais là où vous
avez raison c'est que aujourd'hui c'est
une première défaite pour lui mais moi
j'ai l'intention de faire en sorte que
la mobilisation se poursuive donc de
l'appuyer de soutenir les manifestations
la grève la motion de chaussures pour
faire en sorte qu'on ait une deuxième
victoire et que cette fois cette
deuxième victoire ça soit le fait que ce
texte de loi ne voit pas le jour voilà
aujourd'hui le gouvernement a déjà perdu
on n'a pas encore tout à fait gagner
mais pour ça il faut continuer la
mobilisation
je sais pas on y travaille on va faire
en sorte en tout cas ça va être déposé
dans les prochaines heures voilà ça
c'est clair
c'est pas moi qui le décide mais je
crois avoir lu depuis plusieurs jours
que l'Inter syndicale de manière assez
large assez unanime à indiquer que dans
l'hypothèse ou le gouvernement avait
recours à l'article 49-3 de la
Constitution ce serait un acte qui va
pousser à ce que la mobilisation
notamment se poursuit mais en plus
s'amplifie donc moi je le dis si la
terre syndicale et je le souhaite
prennent des initiatives prendre des
prochaines initiatives pour renforcer
encore le mouvement de grève appel à de
nouvelles dates de manifestations et de
mobilisation on sera à leur côté on sera
en appui de ces différentes initiatives
et nous on continuera à faire ce qu'on
fait depuis le début c'est-à-dire
essayer d'aider les salariés qui se
mettent en mouvement développer la
caisse de grève que nous avons déposée
faire le travail dans la société pour
convaincre convaincre que oui la
mobilisation elle peut permettre de
gagner et je veux dire aux salariés aux
gens qui ont manifesté aujourd'hui vous
avez pas fait tout ça pour rien et la
première preuve que vous avez pas de
fait tout ça pour rien c'est ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui parce que s'il y
avait pas eu une telle de la rue on n'en
serait pas arrivé à ce résultat
aujourd'hui donc je leur dis vous voyez
que ça sert à quelque chose de se
mobiliser continuer à le faire si on
continue tous ensemble on va gagner
j'ai entendu et c'est une très bonne
chose moi je trouve ça très bien quand
l'intersyndicale unise qui est assez
inédit depuis plusieurs années dans ce
pays prends des initiatives de
mobilisation donc si décide de nouvelles
dates nous serons à leur côté si la
grève se poursuit nous serons aux côtés
des grévistes si des grévistes veulent
notre soutien sur des piquets de grève
nous serons à leur côté s'il y a besoin
de soutien financier nous serons à leurs
côtés la bataille continue
merci à vous
la bataille continue à dire manuel
Bompard et c'est ce qu'on dit tout à
l'heure les insoumis n'ont pas
l'intention de la chair non non ils ont
pas l'intention de lâcher et en haut au
fond le recours au 49-3 leur donne 48
heures de répit si il y avait une
discussion normale là ils auraient fait
les fameuses motions et ensuite il y
aurait eu le vote sur le texte et le
texte était voté on en parlait plus
après 17h18 heures et donc là c'était
plus compliqué pour eux de prolonger le
combat ils ont tenté évidemment mais
c'est difficile là on voit bien qu'il y
a encore 24 à 48 heures où ils peuvent
mettre la pression essayer de construire
quelque chose alors c'est quelque chose
qui ne peut pas être constructif par
définition puisque pour que les
oppositions soient majoritaires on l'a
dit tout à l'heure il va falloir
mettre ensemble la carpe et le lapin
absolument rien
affronter aux élections législatives il
y a moins d'un an il faut quand même se
rappeler que c'est les élections
législatives ont eu lieu il y a moins
d'un an c'était en juin 2022 on est en
mars 2023 et tout ça est en train de
voler en éclat donc là tout le monde est
réuni au sein de des groupes chaque
groupe se réunit très peu de temps
finalement on attendait une grande
après-midi avec potentiellement des
débats qui dureraient jusqu'à 18 19 20h
minuit ça c'est ce qui se serait passé
en temps normal 149 ans à arriver une
petite demi-heure 20 minutes avec en
plus une interruption de séance au début
et donc là que se passe-t-il là qu'on
discute dans chaque bureau se réunit
dans son coin ils sont pas tous dans les
groupes puisque on va demander à Julien
Leclerc de tourner la caméra on voit
notamment François Ruffin ici avec
certaines figures
qui viennent et qui reste ici pour
parler aux journalistes mais c'est là
c'est très drôle ce sont ici ah oui
pourquoi tout à l'heure je me suis
glissé un peu sur le côté au moment où
Mathilde panot parlait avec sa voix très
forte et on voyait François Ruffin un
peu en retrait qui n'attendait qu'une
seule chose c'est de pouvoir lui enfin
prendre la parole parce que c'est là où
on revient à ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure c'est quand même un jeu de
d'image un jeu
un théâtre voilà il attendait son tour
et maintenant il vient devant les
caméras
c'est pareil parce que Mathilde panneau
il a président du groupe donc c'était la
première mais les autres ils ont envie
de parler ils ont envie de passer à la
télévision eux aussi c'est humain et ben
voilà donc maintenant c'est son moment
de voir vous voyez il a toutes les
caméras toutes les perches devant lui
quasiment plus que lui dans les députés
dans cette salle des quatre colonnes
parce que tous les autres font leur
travail que font-ils ils sont en réunion
de groupe pour essayer de discuter
stratégie qui va déposer la motion de
censure et puis surtout ça c'est sur la
forme avec qui on s'associe jusqu'où on
va dans cette motion de censure par
exemple on peut se dire allez qui
déposent je me mets à la place d'un
député ça suffit pas je me mets à la
place d'un député insoumis et dans une
réunion des insoumis là en ce moment
s'il y a dépose une motion de censure on
la vote oui voilà si le RN vaut une
motion de censure on la vote non voilà
c'est ça qui est en train d'être avec
exactement bon ça c'est ce qui est aussi
est en train d'être ajuster c'est
clignote ils ne sont que 20 dans leur
groupe oui est-ce que les vins vont
déposer la notion de censure peut-être
ça peut faire 18 19 mais surtout la
question c'est qui va s'associer à
l'iode pour déposer la motion de censure
parce qu'il faut
de mémoire c'est 48 députés qui déposent
la motion de censure donc il faut un
certain nombre de député
il faut qu'elle ait le soutien d'autres
députés exactement qui eux ne peuvent
pas voter pour plusieurs motions de
censure on ne peut pas aussi enfin en
tout cas
elle est si peu donnée quelques
quelle est la cohérence parce que du
coup il y a de déposant sa notion de
censure c'est eux qui vont porter cette
notion de censure et quelle thématique
ils sont aussi sur la retraite
pour les Français les Français vont pas
regarder dans le détail ce qu'il y a
c'est vraiment oui d'accord il devrait
parce que c'est le fond mais non mais
c'est important de censure ce n'est pas
toujours la même il y a toujours une
justification c'est ça la motion de
censure telle qu'elle a été décidé dans
la Constitution c'est d'essayer de
démontrer que la majorité n'est plus
majoritaire au Parlement et qu'il y a
une majorité alternative donc
aujourd'hui ce qui sont en train de
faire c'est de créer une majorité
alternative d'essayer de trouver une
majorité alternative
vous êtes aussi agent de sécurité
c'est le contraire de BFM les bousculer
mais c'est pour montrer que c'est
compliqué même si c'est moins compliqué
de tout à l'heure ça y est ça s'est
calmé et d'ailleurs on va voir voilà une
fois que le calme va revenir chacun va
peut-être reprendre ses esprits bon et
se rendre compte que tout ça voilà il y
a eu l'excitation maintenant est-ce
qu'il y a une majorité alternative et
encore vous avez pas pris trop de coups
mais est-ce que vous êtes grand c'est
vrai c'est vrai je me suis faufilé on a
l'impression que vous avez plus grand
que moi ce qui est pas vrai mais sinon
mais sinon et notre pauvre caméraman
aussi c'est pris du coup parce que nous
encore on est en retraites au milieu là
de la meute
parce que c'est vrai que les gens qui
nous regardent bon bah nous voir parler
nous écoutent mais il voit pas forcément
ce qu'il y a et comment ça se passe et
là encore c'est calme tout à l'heure ça
se bousculer tout le monde voulait avoir
le meilleur angle de caméra la meilleure
prise de vue le son et donc c'était
compliqué bon alors Carl moi ma dernière
question pour savoir si oui ou non on
arrête direct est-ce que des députés de
la majorité vont venir nous voir oui
soyez patient je les vois et là ils sont
en gros en réunion de groupe il faut
déterminer les éléments de langage
d'accord mettez-vous à leur place ils
espéraient quand même un vote certains
que les députés espérer quand même voter
oui on imagine c'est leur boulot
reprenez les les interventions de la
matinée le président du MoDem Mattei
disait non je suis confiant ça veut
passer d'autres
[Musique]
aussi celle des quatre colonnes disait
oui oui ça va passer ça va être juste
mais ça faisait bon ça passe pas il y a
49-3 il faut le justifier donc il faut
prendre des éléments de langage il faut
aussi savoir quoi répondre aux
comportement des députés les filles qui
ont essayé d'empêcher la première
ministre de parler c'est quand même un
comportement très particulier au sein de
l'Assemblée nationale c'est pas la
première fois que ça arrive j'avais
Guillaume rocade votre patron qui me
disait que il n'est pas qu'on a
insultait même les les ministres qui
étaient sur les bancs donc c'est le jeu
de l'Assemblée nationale d'une certaine
manière alors c'est le jeu et ça c'était
le jeu sous la Troisième peut-être la
quatrième sous la 5e c'était quand même
un peu plus pacifié et même
récemment c'est devenu très beaucoup
moins pacifié depuis cette législature
depuis que il y a des députés et les
filles qui ont décidé de semer le chaos
parce que du chaos on l'écoute François
Ruffin et parce qu'on a d'autres caméras
et donc on l'écoute et députés de la
France insoumise
président
[Musique]
c'est évident qu'aujourd'hui c'est la
nation de français surcroît quatre
salariés sur ça tous ceux qui ont tenu
le pays de goût dans le cœur de la
grosse communauté soignant les
enseignants les charismatiques les
pensionnaires les auxiliaires de vie les
agents d'entretien quand on leur parle
de plus en plus c'est donc on a qu'une
nation qui aujourd'hui s'opposent
Emmanuel Macron le champ pour le carnet
c'est la Marseillaise
je viens de voir arriver Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan qui a un habitué de la
salle des quatre colonnes
bon vous me disiez que on aura dans la
soirée d'explication parce que là on est
entendu Elisabeth borne elle est venue
au pupitre de l'Assemblée nationale pour
s'exprimer pour expliquer qu'elle a
activé le 49.3 et maintenant on a besoin
d'explications oui alors j'ai pas
d'informations pour le coup mais ça me
paraîtrait pas illogique que
Elisabeth borne face à un 20h soit TF1
soit France 2 pour pouvoir s'expliquer
parce que il y a besoin d'explications
pourquoi ce recours au 49-3 nous on le
sait on a on a suivi les débats mais
tous les Français les ont pas suivi et
surtout je suis pas sûr que son
explication de texte à l'Assemblée sous
les hués sous les cris ou les
vociférations des députés de la France
insoumise soit audible quand ça passe
à la télévision donc il va y avoir
besoin
d'une explication à mon sens
si elle l'a fait pas c'est quand même
difficile d'autant plus que vous évoquez
tout à l'heure les les mouvements
sociaux et le fait qui est les leaders
syndicaux qui sont venus en dehors de
l'Assemblée Laurent Berger Philippe
Martinez et qui ont le sait
on prévenus que s'il y avait un 49-3 ça
pouvait
radicaliser encore plus le mouvement en
tout cas entraîner la CFDT plus loin que
ce que le voulait au départ alors en
berger donc ça va
il y a une c'est pas une crise politique
puisque c'est un moment politique un peu
tendu mais il peut y avoir là pour le
coup le début d'une crise sociale et
donc ils avaient de borne doit devrait
s'expliquer pour au moins essayer de
mettre un peu de calme dans cette
histoire merci calme je vous promet le
micro merci de nous avoir ajouté alors
vous allez le donner à walibardas
alors pour le coup mais si vous voulez
d'ailleurs donnez votre micro à wali je
vous laisse avec grand plaisir avec
grand plaisir merci beaucoup carmenus
merci Wally Bordas bonjour bonjour
journaliste au service politique du
Figaro et c'est vous qui suivez le
Parlement au jour le jour l'Assemblée
nationale notamment bon votre analyse
sur ce qui s'est passé on a appris au
tout dernier moment que Elisabeth borne
avait utilisé le 49 3 on a appris 20
minutes je pense à peu près avant donc
début la séance à 15h vous me dites à
moins qu'un moins 20 on apprend que que
borne va va déclencher le le 49-3 donc
nous les journalistes c'est vrai qu'on
était tous là salle des quatre colonnes
impatient un peu dans la dans les
spectative dans le dans le suspense de
d'attendre qu'elle a qu'elle a été la
décision de l'exécutif on avait des
députés qui étaient là on voyait quand
même on sentait quand même arrivé ouais
il y avait une mine un peu un peu des
fêtes un peu parce que les députés
Renaissance en tout cas de la majorité
c'est deux que vous me parlez j'imagine
on des infos qui remontent ils ont des
réunions entre eux ils savent que ça va
se passer comme ça et puis je pense
qu'il sentait depuis ce matin quand même
que l'ambiance était de plus en plus au
49-3 de plus en plus au doute sur
l'issue du vote ils avaient eu aussi
leurs collègues des républicains qui
leur avait fait remonter des des
derniers chiffres de de potentiel
votants qui étaient pas très bon donc il
y avait l'Atmos l'atmosphère était au
49-3 à peu près à partir de 14h on
sentait les choses arriver bon 49-3 donc
activé par Elisabeth vous étiez donc
dans dans l'hémicycle au balcon c'est
comme ça qu'on fait bon alors
racontez-moi elle est arrivée
marseillaise pancarte brandie par la
gauche exactement il est arrivé la
gauche avait préparé son coup on avait
on a vu les pancartes tout de suite
ce qui est assez assez drôle c'est que
la gauche a été suivie par le
rassemblement national et par une partie
des républicains marseillaise dans la
première
dans la toute première ensuite dans les
dans les Marseillais suivantes ils ont
continué tout seul les insoumis on
surveille pardon parce que c'est vrai
qu'il y a toujours une agitation on voit
notamment Olivier fort ici Julien
Leclerc va peut-être pouvoir nous le
montrer le patron des socialistes alors
on l'a déjà vu tout à l'heure je vous
propose qu'on l'écoute je vais essayer
de tendre le micro et puis on continue
et vous me racontez ce que vous avez vu
dans cette émission
ce que je veux le projet de loi qui a
été déposé qui est maintenant qui sera
réputé adopter après quelques jours pas
besoin de censure bien ne rentre jamais
dans la réalité des Françaises et les
Français je souhaite que donc ce projet
puisse être un moment retiré ça suppose
ça suppose qu'on puisse nous quitter
toutes les femmes du droit qui nous
reste je me censure
sur un sujet
directement je vois aussi que nickel a
déjà
ok nous participons simplement parce que
l'évidence c'est qu'il y a aujourd'hui
vise démocratique pour reprendre les
mots de Laurent Berger qui est
maintenant manifeste voilà un
gouvernement qui n'a pas de majorité
dans le pays n'est pas une majorité à
l'Assemblée et qui continue ce scandale
démocratique en s'imposant par la force
systématiquement là où il faudrait
chercher au contraire le consensus
rechercher à trouver les voies d'une
réforme qui pourrait être partagée par
le plus grand nombre malheureusement on
le voit bien ce président n'a toujours
pas compris qu'il n'avait pas de
majorité à l'Assemblée
c'est une violence faite au Parlement
est faite aux françaises et aux Français
qui depuis deux mois répète avec
constance avec force qu'ils sont
opposées cette réforme et
malheureusement un gouvernement un
président essentiellement qui s'obstine
et qui par caprice considère que sa
volonté de s'imposer à tout le monde
mais je ne sais pas si pour moi c'est
pas la question la question c'est
j'appelle au retrait de ce projet de loi
si le président ne veut pas prendre le
risque d'un embrasement général et bien
il coupe maintenant retirer cette
réforme et toi comprendre que à la fois
cette réforme en elle-même et l'usage 49
à faire passer une violence qui est pour
les français et qui donc on risque celui
d'une
autre aussi de dérive que je ne veux pas
de pied à ce stade mais pendant tout le
monde comprend la dangerosité et donc
moi je souhaite que le Président de la
République cherche l'apaisement et que
il retrouve la voix de la raison et pour
cela qu'il obtient son projet
nous verrons mais enfin moi je n'ai pas
peur de la dissolution considère que
quand on
a une solution et elle veut un moment
recourir au peuple qui est le seul
souverain dans ce pays et bien il peut
le faire s'il veut dissoudre demain
matin qu'il le fasse et on verra bien
qui a raison
ça lui dise est-ce qu'ils sont
favorables à une réforme qui est
à 64 ans au contraire il préfère rester
là où nous en sommes aujourd'hui
on en est allé discuter et ne vous
inquiétez pas elle sera déposé
c'est la discussion ça dépend ça dépend
pas que de nous nous sommes toujours
prêts à déposer nos sensations parce que
nous considérons que il y a là donc
une forme d'évidence et qui a une
réplique à apporter face à cette
violence mentale mais le périmètre de
signature n'est pas encore défini ça
dépendra de ce que chacun souhaite
non moi je ne souhaite rien signer avec
mais là aussi ça viendra dans les
prochaines heures vous aurez tous les
éléments et vous saurez tout mais nous
sommes en train de discuter avec les uns
et les autres c'est la meilleure façon
de continuer le combat et de ne pas se
laisser marcher sur les pieds par un
président qui considère que à lui seul
il prendra sa décision pour tous
comment
quand il déteste il se venait d'entendre
Olivier Faure le patron des socialistes
alors c'est assez intéressant parce que
Marine Le Pen est la seule qui est venue
s'exprimer ici pour le rassemblement
national du côté de laupes et de LFI on
en a vu beaucoup venir ici prendre la
parole on a moins d'incarnation de ce
point de vue là exactement et ça ça se
voit aussi dans l'hémicyclin d'ailleurs
on parlait tout à l'heure de ce qui
s'est passé dans l'Assemblée nationale
au moment où Elisabeth borne est arrivé
alors
Bronka courte suspension de séance c'est
ça et ensuite ça c'est drôle je vais
parler de la suspension de séance
pendant la suspension de séance nous
journaliste on est obligé de sortir de
l'hémicycle on arrive derrière et on
voit juste en dessous de nous les le
public les visiteurs qui sont venus
là on voit Jean-Luc Mélenchon Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui jubile
en train de pianoter sur son téléphone
portable et des décrire assez députés
des féliciter on voit cette scène là et
on rentre dans l'hémicycle et ça reprend
on reprend exactement pareil avec la
Marseillaise etc cette fois par contre
les autres groupes le RN et LR etc etc
également ne suivent pas d'accord les
LFI chantent la Marseillaise tout au
long de l'intervention d'Elizabeth borne
on entend rien nous nous dans l'hémicy
on entend absolument nous on était ici
on entendait évidemment le micro
d'Elisabeth donc on entendait pas bien
le fond et on la sentait quand même
poussé la voir
son micro porte et qu'on entend
finalement qu'elle à la télévision elle
est obligée elle ne s'entendait
peut-être pas elle-même en tout cas nous
nous nous l'entendions pas j'ai dû
entendre trois quatre mots de
l'intervention j'ai réécouter après
justement la capsule vidéo sur Twitter
pour pouvoir voir ce qu'elle avait dit
on entend que les champs des insoumis
les cris des députés du rassemblement
national en tant que l'ambiance sonore
qui est assez agréable et qui fait
presque mal aux oreilles en fait quand
on ressort de là Jean-Luc Mélenchon
peut-être qu'on peut avoir une analyse
sur sa présence ça vous a étonné c'est
vrai qu'on dit les journalistes disent
oui c'est lui qui tient les manettes qui
tient les manettes qui tire les ficelles
là c'est une représentation pure et dure
il y a plus de discussion il est là et
il joue le rôle du marinisme est-ce que
c'est exactement stratégique c'est le
chef des agitateurs qui ont coulissent
jubile de voir ses troupes menées à la
perfection la chorégraphie qui la
lui-même orchestré donc c'est assez
c'est assez intéressant de de ce point
de vue là et et en plus tout au long de
cette séquence des retraites il a été
omniprésent c'est lui aussi qui
orchestré les le l'obstruction
parlementaire et je lis souvent dans les
colonnes du Figaro et par tout ailleurs
que oui il est là il est dans l'ombre
alors on le voit un peu sur les
manifestations mais là c'est net c'est
clair pour tous les Français c'est lui
qui a réussi son coup d'une certaine
manière en forçant ses débat longuement
longtemps et on arrivant à ce 49-3 qui
est d'une certaine manière est une
défaite pour le gouvernement exactement
il y a sa présence physique qui qui
vient exactement manifester ça bon Wally
je me posais la question vous êtes un
habitué on a vu beaucoup de députés de
l'opposition venir ici quand est-ce
qu'on va voir les députés de la majorité
alors les députés de la majorité moi je
les ai vu ah vous avez vu
dans la cour derrière
donc la mine la mine a battu hein
hier soir encore les les patrons de
groupe hors berger Marc Angeli pour
horizon Mattéi pour pour le modem
plaidait encore pour pour aller au vote
je pense que ce matin c'était encore le
cas donc il y a une vraie déception pour
eux de de ne pas être allé au scrutin et
quand on les a vu partir vraiment voilà
tête basse quoi d'accord une grosse
déception d'avoir vu ce 49,3 j'ai vu des
députés des rép notamment qui était en
faveur de cette réforme dire je suis
querais je suis curieux parce que les
députés des républicains eux ils
auraient ils ne défendent pas et
Elisabeth borne certaine manière mais il
voulait voter la réforme donc qu'est-ce
qui désintéressait le plus c'était le
vote hein il s'en moque finalement de
victoire d'une défaite d'Elizabeth
d'ailleurs tous hein autant ceux qui
étaient favorables à la réforme que te
que ceux qui étaient défavorables à la
réforme chez les républicains vous
voulez aller au vote parce que
finalement c'était pas leur
c'était pas leur combat
je sais pas si on coulisse ça ne les
arrange finalement pas ce 49-3 étant
donné les divisions qui avaient entre
eux là au moins avec le 49-3 c'est
finalement l'option peut peut-être les
arranger le plus étant donné que il y a
pas de vote on peut pas dire les LR sont
divisés il y en a trop de que voter pour
30 que voter contre bon dernière
question alors que il y a des
manifestants autour de l'Assemblée
nationale vous avez pu voir certaines
images les créatures qui étaient en
régie au Figaro et qui vous montre s'il
se passe si c'est l'Assemblée nationale
et en dehors de l'Assemblée nationale
avec toujours ces manifestants
est-ce que vous m'avez dit que vous avez
vu les députés de la majorité ils ont
une mine défaite mais ils sont bien
obligés de défendre ce choix d'Elizabeth
borne oui mais dans l'hémicycle aussi
j'ai trouvé ça assez frappant de voir la
division des députés de la majorité il y
en avait qui étaient debout qui
applaudissait l'intervention d'Elizabeth
borne je pense qu'ils étaient environ
une vingtaine et je dirais que c'est le
noyau dur autour d'Aurore berger toute
voilà ce qu'on appelle la team berger
ils étaient debout ils applaudissaient
etc les autres étaient avachis sur leur
siège tête baissée et bon ils ont un peu
dit à la fin mais le cœur n'y était pas
bon donc je pense qu'il y a vraiment une
grosse déception sur l'issue de l'issue
de cette réforme en tout cas pour
l'instant les députés qui passent en
voient notamment Julien Bayou ici
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts qui est
juste là est-ce qu'on n'irait pas dans
la salle d'à côté il me semble qu'il y a
des députés qui terminus m'a fait signe
on va essayer de voir si on peut venait
Wally on va essayer dans d'en trouver
des députés de la majorité on avance et
on va voir si on peut poser certaines
questions alors qu'on va par exemple ici
vers l'extérieur de de l'Assemblée
nationale Jérôme Guedj notamment le
socialiste on va essayer d'aller dans la
salle à côté des pas perdus
oui je vais vous relâcher dans un
instant parce que je sais que vous avez
des papiers à faire pour pour Le Figaro
bon quelle analyse vous portez sur ce
qu'il risque de se passer dans les
heures qui viennent que va-t-il se
passer vous êtes un spécialiste de
l'Assemblée vous savez vous connaissez
les petits détails là motion de censure
c'est ça va se passer quoi jusqu'à
vendredi peut-être qu'il va rien se
passer d'ici vendredi déjà peut-être
qu'il va rien se passer d'ici vendredi
il y a eu bon effectivement il y a des
notions qui vont être déposées
manifestement par le rassemblement
national manifestement par la France
insoumise nups enfin on va voir
peut-être même une transpartisane avec
l'iode le groupe liberté territoire et
indépendant qui sera à la manœuvre donc
peut-être qu'il y aura trois notions de
censure on verra ce qu'il en est un peu
plus tard
ensuite dans les heures qui viennent la
Présidence de l'Assemblée la Conférence
des Présidents va se réunir pour voir
quand vont être étudiés ces émotions de
censure on parle de on parle déjà de
samedi peut-être lundi
on verra dans les jours qui viennent
mais dans tous les cas c'est ça la
prochaine étape systémotion de censions
là sont rejetées la réforme sera adoptée
si c'est émotions de censure enfin si
l'une de ces motions de censure en
l'occurrence celle de l'iode la
transpartisane pourrait avoir plus de
chance de toutes les oppositions
exactement on a des élus LR j'ai vu tout
à l'heure Pierre-Henri Dumont j'ai
député du Nord qui disait qu'il pourrait
voter cette notion trans partisane voire
même la signer donc voilà le suspense il
va être autour de ça
l'analyse elle est claire il y a une
vingtaine de députés LR qui voulait
voter contre cette réforme si on mettait
la vingtaine de députés à l'air qui
voulaient voter contre cette réforme qui
vote une motion de censure pour
l'instant ça ne suffit pas à faire
tomber
de borne tout à l'heure à tuer le
suspense mais que provisoirement puisque
nous auront à nouveau un vote
probablement un vote à suspens dans les
48 heures qui viennent voilà et qui peut
s'annoncer beaucoup plus serré que les
précédentes motion de censure merci
beaucoup ALI bardah
je vous dis à bientôt alors on va rester
en ici à l'Assemblée nationale on va
essayer d'avoir encore quelques
réactions de certains députés notamment
ceux de la majorité et je vous annonce
aussi que Elisabeth land sera journal
télévisé ce soir de la première chaîne
de télévision française elle est obligée
de d'expliquer son choix tout à fait
nous nous suivrons ça évidemment merci
de nous avoir suivi excellente journée
excellente après-midi sur le figarolive
[Musique]
un tout petit peu comme ça voilà non
mais du coup c'est juste un peu
[Musique]